today also marks the start of an
experiment Gail for at least three
states in partially reopening as the
national death toll climbs to about
50,000 people they include Alaska
Oklahoma and Georgia
mark Strassmann is in Atlanta mark our
folks they're comfortable with this well
we're gonna find out today Anthony we'll
see who shows up to these businesses
that are going to reopen and salons are
among the businesses allowed to reopen
and this one behind me is going to go
for it it's a controversial decision by
Georgia Governor Brian Kemp and even his
fellow Republicans including President
Trump have lit into him for it I think
locals needed to have more input and
it's made people nervous Georgia
Republican Congressman Doug Collins is
questioning his Republican governor
Brian Kemp for his decision to open
parts of the state's economy this
morning it is a scary time to be opening
back up jason griggers owns escape hair
salon just outside of atlanta he's
reopening his doors today but with
reservations the biggest concern is that
somebody's gonna come in here Adam attic
have the virus and uh and it's gonna
pass to one of us or to one of our
clients President Trump again criticized
Georgia's governor for his decision to
reopen the state's economy I'm not happy
about it and I'm not happy about Brian
Kemp even states that have yet to lift
restrictions are seeing more people out
in public in Orange County California
about 9,000 people crowded Huntington
Beach on Thursday I worried a little bit
about social distancing because clearly
it's not happening and in New York as
new hospitalization rates slowly drop
the political battle over a federal
bailout four states hit hard by the
outbreak is heating up how ugly a
thought New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
hit back a Kentucky senator Mitch
McConnell the majority leader suggested
states could declare bankruptcy rather
than getting more federal dollars
referring to that option as blue state
bailouts just think of what he's saying
people died
fifteen thousand people died in New York
but they were predominantly Democrats so
why should we help them the latest
stimulus bill passed by Congress does
not include money for state funding the
Midwest Center for Investigative
Reporting says about thirty four hundred
reported positive kovat cases are tied
to the meatpacking industry across 23
states including Nebraska governor Pete
Ricketts I don't foresee a scenario
where I would tell them to close at my
workplace people are working shoulders
to shoulder a chewed dange a single
mother of three works at the Smithfield
pork plant in South Dakota it closed
after more than 800 people tested
positive for the corona virus she was
one of them it's very hard when you are
at home sick and try to take care of the
little one try to keep distancing at the
same time many businesses are business
owners reopening today are skittish
about it a different salon than this one
is making customers sign this waiver
it's essentially a promise that if you
come down with kovat 19 you won't sue
Tony yeah it's scary to reopen but also
scary economically to stay close to mark
thank you very much